This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1920, a Dutch writer named Rard Nolst Trenetet published a poem in English titled The Chaos. It's theme, spelling, specifically English spelling and pronunciation, and all the chaos it has let loose upon the world, it begins. Dearest creature in creation, studying English pronunciation, I will teach you in my verse sounds like corpse, core, horse, and worse. I will make you, Susie, busy. Make your head with heat grow dizzy.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯 (Roman Mars)。1920年，一位名叫拉德·诺尔斯特·特雷内特 (Rard Nolst Trenetet) 的荷兰作家发表了一首英文诗，名为《混乱》(The Chaos)。它的主题是拼写，特别是英语拼写和发音，以及它释放给全世界的所有混乱。它以这样的话开头：亲爱的造物创造者，在研究英语发音，我将在我的诗句中教你听起来像 corpse、core、horse 和 worse 的声音。我会让你苏西 (Susie) 忙碌 (busy)。让你的脑袋因发热而晕眩 (dizzy)。
Just compare heart, hear, and heard, dies, and die at, Lord, and Word. And that's just the opening lines. The full poem goes on for another 66 stances. Tryna-te design the poem as a pronunciation exercise, a catchy jingle to help students of English learn what he called the languages, quote, phonetic paradoxes, but still he couldn't help but end the poem on a note of despair. Which rhymes with enough, though through plow, cough, hoof, or tough, hiccup as the sound of sup. My advice is, give it up. The absurdity of this poem works because let's face it, when it comes to English spelling
只要对比一下 heart、hear 和 heard，dies 和 die at，Lord 和 Word。而这还只是开头的几行。整首诗还有另外 66 个小节。特雷内特把这首诗设计为一个发音练习，一个朗朗上口的打油诗，用来帮助英语学生学习他所谓的语言“语音悖论”，但他仍然忍不住在绝望中结束了这首诗。与 enough 押韵的词有 though、plough、cough、hoof 或 tough，hiccup 的发音就像 sup。我的建议是，放弃吧。这首诗的荒谬之处在于，让我们面对现实吧，当谈到英语拼写
and pronunciation, there is plenty of rhyme and very little reason. But what is the reason for that? Why among all European languages is English so uniquely chaotic today? To help us answer that question, we're talking to linguist in long time in front of the show, Erika O'Krant, author of the new book, Highly Irregular. Why tough, through, and doe, don't rhyme, and other oddities of the English language. In it, Erika explores the origins of those phonetic paradoxes, and it turns out that some of the English language. In it, Erika explores the origins of those phonetic paradoxes, and it turns out that some of the reasons for the confusion are as counterintuitive as the words themselves. Erika, welcome back to 99 and I'm FI. Thanks so much. It's great to be here.
和发音时，有大量的押韵，却几乎没有什么规律。但背后的原因是什么呢？为什么在所有欧洲语言中，今天的英语如此独特而混乱？为了帮我们解答这个问题，我们采访了语言学家、节目的老朋友埃里卡·奥克兰特 (Erika O'Krant)，她是新书《极不规则》(Highly Irregular) 的作者。为什么 tough、through 和 doe 不押韵，以及英语的其他古怪之处。在书中，埃里卡探讨了这些语音悖论的起源，事实证明，英语中的某些原因......在书中，埃里卡探讨了这些语音悖论的起源，事实证明，混乱的一些原因和单词本身一样违反直觉。埃里卡，欢迎回到 99，我是 FI。非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。
So Erika, what is going on? English is notoriously screwy, but what happened to make our language, or at least the written language, so ridiculous? Well, I should say, I don't know if I mentioned this, the original working title of the book was, What the Hell English? And that's sort of the, that's the mood of it. That's the, that's the emotion that we're doing here. What the Hell English? Why are you like this? Why are you so weird? And you might say there's two broad reasons. One reason is that there have been a lot of people over the years who have intentionally tried to improve the language by improving its vocabulary or improving the spelling in various ways. And then most of those attempts kind of backfired and just made things more confusing. But the even bigger reason written English is so inconsistent is actually something that happened
那么埃里卡，到底是怎么回事？英语出了名的古怪，但究竟发生了什么，让我们的语言，或者至少是书面语言，变得如此荒谬？嗯，我应该说，我不知道我是否提过，这本书最初的工作标题是《英语到底是怎么回事？》(What the Hell English?)。这有点像是，这就是它的情绪。这就是我们在这里所做的事情所表达的情绪。英语到底是怎么回事？你为什么会这样？你为什么这么奇怪？你可能会说有两个广泛的原因。一个原因是，多年来有很多人曾试图通过改善词汇或以各种方式改善拼写来刻意改进这门语言。然后，其中大部分尝试都适得其反，反而让事情变得更混乱。但书面语言如此不一致的更深层原因，其实是一件发生得
more accidentally. And that was the introduction of the printing press to England in the 15th century, which is ironic because you'd think, of course, that the printing press would help make spelling more consistent. But in the case of English, that the printing press would help make spelling more consistent. But in the case of English, it had the opposite effect. So, let's talk about this introduction of the printing press at the moment that it hit the English language. How did the first press that was make it to England? Well, the first printing press brought to England was brought by William Caxton.
更加偶然的事情。那就是在 15 世纪将印刷机引入英格兰，这具有讽刺意味的是，你自然会认为印刷机会有助于使拼写更加一致。但在英语的情况下，印刷机却产生了相反的效果。所以，让我们来谈谈印刷机刚刚传入英格兰的那一刻。第一台印刷机是如何来到英格兰的？嗯，带到英格兰的第一台印刷机是由威廉·卡克斯顿 (William Caxton) 带来的。
He was a merchant and he wasn't, you know, of the upper, upper classes, but he was working in Belgium and Bruges and he found this printing technology, which was very new at the time. He grabbed onto it and printed a popular English translation that he had done of this, the Legend of Troy, for members of the Burgundian court in the Netherlands that were English speakers. And it was light and popular and entertaining and not a big literary endeavor. It was just very popular and he spotted that business opportunity right away. Oh, if you do something fun and popular, people want it, and they'll buy it, and that's a merchant's dream. So he brought the Flamish-speaking typesetters that he had been
他是一个商人，你知道的，他不是上流社会的人，但他当时在比利时和布鲁日工作，他发现了这种在当时非常新颖的印刷技术。他抓住了这个机会，为荷兰勃艮第宫廷的英语使用者印刷了一本他自己翻译的广受欢迎的英文译本《特洛伊传奇》(The Legend of Troy)。它轻松、受欢迎、有趣，不是什么宏大的文学著作。它只是非常受欢迎，他立刻发现了这个商机。哦，如果你做一些有趣且受欢迎的事情，人们就会想要它，他们就会买它，这就是商人的梦想。所以他把他一直在布鲁日合作的
working with from Bruges and started printing English books in England. So when Caxson arrived back in England with his press, like you said, you'd expect it to maybe help regulate the language, but kind of the opposite happened. So what was it about English at this moment in the 15th century that made it not play nice with the printing press, like as opposed to other languages? Well, the way to think about it is that all languages from time to time go through big changes. Languages everywhere are always changing in the way they're spoken and written, but what happened with most other European languages is that their big shifts either happened before
讲弗拉芒语的排字工人带到了英格兰，开始在英格兰印刷英文书籍。所以当卡克斯顿带着他的印刷机回到英格兰时，就像你说的，你本期望它或许能帮助规范语言，但发生的却是截然相反的事情。那么，在 15 世纪这个时期，英语有什么特点，使得它不像其他语言那样与印刷机“友好相处”呢？嗯，思考这个问题的方式是，所有语言不时都会经历重大变化。各地的语言在口语和书面语的使用上总是在变化的，但大多数其他欧洲语言发生的情况是，它们的重大转变要么发生在
or after the printing press arrived. And if your language goes through a big change before the printing press arrives, that's okay because the changes are happened, they've been completed, and now the writing that you establish can reflect how you speak it now, the changes are done. And if your language goes through its big change after the printing press arrives, that's also okay because the way it's written will then reflect the older system. It might lose some word endings, some letters go silent, some sounds that are no longer pronounced, but even if it's different from the spoken language, has its own kind of internal consistency, which makes it easier to learn. And there's
印刷机到来之前，要么发生在之后。如果你的语言在印刷机到来之前经历了一场大变化，那是没问题的，因为变化已经发生了，已经完成了，现在你确立的书面文字可以反映你现在的说话方式，变化已经结束了。如果你的语言在印刷机到来之后经历重大变化，那也没问题，因为它的书面形式将会反映较旧的系统。它可能会失去一些词尾，一些字母变得不发音，一些不再发音的音，但即使它与口语不同，它也有其自身的内在一致性，这使得它更容易学习。并且一旦你掌握了那个系统，
no big surprises once you've got that system down. I see. But what's really tricky is if your language is going through a big change at the same time that the printing press comes to town, that's where things get really messy. And that's what happened to English. And part of that was because spoken English was undergoing some big changes in pronunciation. But the other reason is that the rules and traditions of written English had more or less just been completely scrambled. Now, old
就不会有太大的惊喜。我明白。但真正棘手的是，如果你的语言在印刷机来到镇上的同时也在经历重大变化，事情就会变得非常混乱。这就是英语所遭遇的。其中一部分原因是口语的发音正在经历一些重大变化。但另一个原因是，书面英语的规则和传统或多或少刚刚被完全打乱了。现在，古
English had very nice, orderly spelling and a well-established tradition in literature. But that was all disrupted with the Norman invasion of 1066. The French came in, they took over all the upper echelons of society, and so writing was in French for a long time, and by the time printing was coming in in the 15th century, English had returned, but it was still on shaky ground, and it wasn't very consistent. There wasn't a book you could get and say, okay, what rule am I following here? What is the proper grammar here? What is the proper spelling here? So English was in deep flux when Caxton arrived with his press. So Caxton brings the printing press to England. He brings
英语有着非常美好、井然有序的拼写和完善的文学传统。但这在 1066 年诺曼征服后全被打乱了。法国人入侵并接管了社会的所有上层阶级，因此很长一段时间内书面文字都是法文，而当 15 世纪印刷术传入时，英语回归了，但它仍然基础不稳，而且很不一致。没有一本书你可以拿来说，好吧，我在这里遵循什么规则？这里的正确语法是什么？这里的正确拼写是什么？因此，当卡克斯顿带着他的印刷机到来时，英语正处于极度的动荡之中。所以卡克斯顿把印刷机带到了英格兰。他带了
his Flamish printers who are not experts in English. There's this kind of no English to be an expert of anyways. Can you describe the process of like why printing itself introduced variations in spelling? Well, when you've got a set type, it's very labor intensive while you're setting it. It buys you all kinds of time once it's set. Then you can print off as much as you like, but while you're setting it, it's very difficult. And sometimes you need to make adjustments because you want the margin to be straight, so maybe you add a letter or take a letter away. And some of the printers that Caxon brought with him were using sort of Flemish style spellings,
他的弗拉芒打印机，他们并不是英语专家。反正也没有什么“英语”可以让他们成为专家的。你能描述一下印刷术本身是如何引入拼写变体这一过程的吗？嗯，当你拥有一套活字时，在排版时是非常劳心费力的。一旦排好，它会为你节省大量时间。然后你可以随心所欲地印制，但在排版时，它是非常困难的。有时你需要做调整，因为你想让页边距是对齐的，所以也许你添加了一个字母或删除了一个字母。卡克斯顿带来的一些打印机使用的是类似弗拉芒风格的拼写，
so they'd see a word like ghost, which would an old English be something like G-A-S-T gust. Will they spell it G-H-E-E-S-T? That's the flammish way. And so they put it in with G-H and that G-H stays for the spelling of ghost which is weird. We don't spell English words starting with G-H that have a hard guss on. That's a strange English spelling, but it perpetuated itself. That one part did, but other parts didn't. So they used to spell girl G-H-E-R-L-E or, you know, there were other other words they did this too, but those didn't catch on. But it did catch on with the word, Google. Yeah, but we didn't have the word Google when printing came in.
所以他们看到像 ghost 这样的词，在古英语中类似于 G-A-S-T gust。他们会把它拼成 G-H-E-E-S-T。那是弗拉芒语的方式。因此，他们把它放入了 G-H，而这个 G-H 就成了 ghost 拼写的保留，这很奇怪。我们不会用以 G-H 开头且带有硬 g 发音的字母来拼写英文单词。那是一个奇怪的英语拼写，但它延续了下来。那一部分留下来了，但其他部分没有。所以他们过去把 girl 拼成 G-H-E-R-L-E 或者，你知道的，还有其他一些词他们也这样做，但那些没有流行起来。但它在 ghoul 这个词上流行起来了。是的，但是当印刷术传入时，我们还没有 ghoul 这个词。
That was a much, much later borrowing. We borrowed from Arabic. And when we took that word in, it's, oh, it's kind of like a ghost. And it should look like, it looked like that. These two words go together and let's give a GH to that one too. And, and so this kind of accidental error takes on its own influence and then spreads to some other part of the language, but not everywhere. So that's an inconsistency. That's just going to stay there.
那是后来借用的词。我们从阿拉伯语中借用的。当我们引入那个词时，哦，它有点像个 ghost。它应该长那样，它看起来就像那样。这两个词放在一起，让我们也给那个词一个 GH 吧。因此，这种偶然的错误产生了自身的影响，然后蔓延到语言的其他部分，但并非到处都是。所以这是一个不一致性。它就会一直留在那。
The double consonant also shows up with a silent W's like wrist hole, who, the silent G in that. What's going on with those, are those also sort of sourced from printing? Well, most of those come from old English. We used to pronounce them, and we pronounced those pretty far into printing so that when printing started, at that point people were still saying the W in words like, who, and rist, and the K in words like, Kno, and Knit. Although in some places they still do the WH thing if you're in the south, or in some places they say, where? Why?
双辅音也出现在不发音的 W 中，比如 wrist、hole、who，以及其中的不发音的 G。这些是怎么回事，它们也是某种源自印刷术的吗？嗯，大多数这些都来自古英语。我们过去常常发音，而且在印刷术出现后的很长一段时间里我们都发音，所以在印刷术开始时，人们在 who、rist 这样的词中仍然发音 W，在 kno、knit 这样的词中发音 K。尽管在某些地方，如果你在南部，或者在某些地方，他们仍然发音 WH，比如 where？why？
Like, that's a thing that the H is there and it was there from old English. And by the time we had stopped saying those things, it was preserved in amber, so they stayed. What are some other sort of common examples of things that you still see in the written language that we just don't pronounce anymore? Or maybe we used to pronounce them and now we've just kind of lost that. Well, a big one is the other G-H that's in so many words, like tough and dough and through and night and might and right and it's everywhere in English, but there's no part of those words that has a g- or a h- sound in it at all. Why is that- what is that G-H doing?
就像，H 在那里，而且从古英语开始就一直在那里。等到我们不再发音这些东西时，它就像被琥珀包裹一样保存了下来，所以它们留了下来。还有哪些其他常见的例子，是你在书面语言中仍然能看到，但我们已经不再发音的？或者也许我们以前发音过，现在只是丢失了？嗯，其中一个大例子是许多单词中都有的另一个 G-H，比如 tough、dough、through、night、might、right，它在英语中无处不在，但这些单词中没有任何一部分带有 g 或 h 的发音。为什么会这样——那个 G-H 在做什么？
Why is it in there? And it got into the spelling when we still were pronouncing that sound, except it wasn't a g- or a h- sound. It was a- on the fly decision made by people who had to write English and had no way of writing this really weird sound that English had and Latin didn't. There was no way to write it in the Latin alphabet. And that was a word we spell in English with a GH. So, nacht, nacht, eight, acht. Any time you lift one of these English GH spellings, you'll find a ch- in the equivalent German
为什么它在里面？当我们在发那个音时，它进入了拼写中，除了它不是 g 或 h 的音。那是那些必须书写英语却又无法拼写出英语拥有而拉丁语没有的这种真正奇怪的发音的人所做出的即兴决定。在拉丁字母中没有办法写出它。那就是我们在英语中用 GH 拼写的词。所以，nacht、nacht、eight、acht。每当你挑出一个这些英语的 GH 拼写时，你都会在对应的德语单词中找到一个 ch 音。
word. And in some words it turned into a f sound. So k'of, laf, those were k'ach and lach. So some words became a f and some words became a nothing. Some words just dropped out and became the vowel. Like we say dough, but there is a British dessert called plum duff and that's the same word. But it's dough that became a duff sound instead of the dough sound. So the chhe became a whole bunch of different possibilities, but none of them lasted as
在有些词中它变成了 f 音。所以 k'of、laf，那些曾经是 k'ach 和 lach。所以有些词变成了 f，有些词什么都不是。有些词直接脱落并变成了元音。就像我们说 dough，但有一个英国甜点叫 plum duff，那是同一个单词。但它是 dough 变成了 duff 的发音，而不是 dough 的发音。所以 chhe 变成了各种各样可能的发音，但没有一个作为 chhe 持续下来。我们只是失去了那个音。并且你在书中写到，这一时期英语中发生的最大变化之一被称为“大元音大变动”(Great Vowel Shift)，同样，它恰好发生在 15 世纪印刷机传入的那个时刻。你能描述一下“大元音大变动”吗？
chhe. We just lost that sound. And one of the biggest changes going on in English in this period that you write about is something called the Great Vowel Shift, which again, it's right about the moment the brain press arrives in the 15th century. Can you describe the Great Vowel Shift? Yeah, the Great Vowel Shift is an explanation for much of the spelling problems in English, because vowels are very vague. So I can describe consonants by telling you where the obstruction happens. So a B, a B, that's the lips coming together to block the sound and then release the sound.
是的，“大元音大变动”解释了英语中大部分的拼写问题，因为元音非常模糊。所以我可以通过告诉你阻塞发生的地方来描述辅音。比如一个 B，一个 B，那是双唇闭合以阻挡声音然后释放声音。
and then release the sound. But the description of how a vowel is, oh, well, the tongue is kind of higher in the mouth and further back, and then your lips are kind around it or not kind of, it's very hard to pin down. Here's how you make this vowel. And so vowels shift around a lot because they are, so they, in the mouth. Yeah. But English went through over the course of a few hundred years, because they are so vague in the mouth.
然后释放声音。但对元音的描述是，哦，好吧，舌头在口腔中位置更高、更靠后，然后你的唇形有点圆起，或者说不是，这很难准确定义。这就是你发出这个元音的方式。因此，元音会发生很大变化，因为它们在口腔中是如此模糊。是的。但在几百年的时间里，英语
But English went through over the course of a few hundred years, a systematic change to the vowel system. So vowels moving from a lower position to a higher position in the mouth, and then the ones that they're bumping into as they move higher, those have to move higher too. So it's sort of a chain. And so you get shifts like bought to boat, but it's displacing boat, which means boot. So the awe moves to oh, the oh moves to ooh. And then that's displacing the u, which has nowhere to go. So it goes into diphthong land. So what used to be huss becomes house. What used to be mousse becomes mouse. But then a little
经历了对元音系统的系统性改变。因此元音从口腔中的较低位置移动到较高位置，随着它们向上移动，它们撞击到的那些元音也必须向上移动。所以这有点像一个连锁反应。因此你得到了诸如 bought 到 boat 的转变，但它排挤了 boat，而 boat 意味着 boot。所以 awe 移动到 oh，oh 移动到 ooh。然后这又排挤了 u，它无处可去。所以它进入了双元音的领地。所以过去是 huss 的变成了 house。过去是 mousse 的变成了 mouse。但随后稍微
later some of them shifted around the corner to u. So buk becomes buk becomes b book, but only some places. In the north of England, they all stay at ooh, so, Luke, book, food, those all stay the same. They're not done with a vowel shift. I mean, why did the great vowel shift happen? I mean, is this just a name to put around a period of time or was there something happening that made it happen at that moment? Well, yeah, that's a big question. Some people think it had to do with the plague and the disruption of populations, the growth of London and the influx of people from various hearts of the country, but it also happened so slowly over so long a time that whatever kicked it off, we can't really say in any one instance why people who used to say mate started saying meat because it has to shift quite a bit before someone takes note and says,
晚一点，其中一些转变成了 u。所以 buk 变成了 buk，变成了 book，但仅限于某些地方。在英格兰北部，它们都停留在 ooh，所以，Luke、book、food，这些都保持不变。它们没有经历元音大变动。我是说，为什么会发生大元音大变动？我的意思是，这只是一个用来代指一段特定时期的名称，还是说当时发生了什么事情导致它在那个时刻发生？嗯，是的，这是一个大问题。有些人认为这与黑死病和人口的中断、伦敦的发展以及来自全国各地的人口的涌入有关，但它发生得太慢、历时太长，以至于无论是什么引发了它，我们真的无法在任何一个实例中说明，为什么那些过去说 mate 的人开始说 meat，因为它必须发生相当大的转变，才会有人注意到并说，
hey, that's a strange pronunciation. Are you from Australia? Or, you know, but by that time, it's usually too late. So we didn't know the great vowel shift was happening when it was happening. And it's still going on. So how do you say R-O-O-F? Roof or roof? Yeah. I kind of have both of this.
嘿，那是个奇怪的发音。你是澳大利亚人吗？或者，你知道的，但到那个时候，通常已经太晚了。所以当元音大变动发生时，我们并不知道它正在发生。而且它仍在继续。那么你如何发 R-O-O-F 的音？Roof 还是 roof？对。我这两种发音都有。
I kind of say both, yeah, actually. But that is a vowel shift, that even in one person, it's not quite completed yet. And so I see why this would wreak havoc if you're trying to set the language down in print, because how would you know how to spell which sound? It sounds like it's a continuous game of whack-mull. It just calls all this variation. Exactly. Because when are you going to change the spelling when everybody's back on that
我两种都说，是的，实际上。但那是一种元音变动，甚至在同一个人身上，它还没有完全完成。所以我也明白，如果你试图把语言固定在印刷品中，这将会带来浩劫，因为你怎么知道哪个发音该怎么拼写？听起来这就像是一场持续不断的打地鼠游戏。它引发了所有的这些变体。正是如此。因为你什么时候要改变拼写呢？当每个人都在
same page, or you only do it for the London speakers and not for the Scottish speakers? And the answer is is sometimes you change it, sometimes you don't, depending on when it got pushed, it's not, let's all spell it the new way. So you can't coordinate it. And then we end up with the vowel mess that we have in English. I mean, the long e-sound is particularly confounding from the list in your book. There's a me, beer, belief, leaf, seas, police, key, mosquito, people, phoenix. All of them are long e-sound. All of them are spelled different. Yeah. I know that's a long page in your mapping of sounds to spellings in English.
同一页纸上的时候？还是你只为伦敦的演讲者改变而不为苏格兰的演讲者改变？答案是，有时你改，有时你不改，这取决于它是什么时候被推动的，这不是“让我们都用新方式拼写”的情况。所以你无法协调。然后我们就落入了英语中那样的元音乱局。我是说，长 e 音从你书中的列表中看尤其令人迷惑。有 me、beer、belief、leaf、seas、police、key、mosquito、people、phoenix。它们全都是长 e 音。它们的拼写全都不一样。是的。我知道在你的英语声音与拼写映射中，那是一个很长的页面。
When we come back, we'll talk to Erica about the oddities in English for which we have only ourselves to blame. We're back with Erika Ogrant, Erika. In your book you say that in addition to all these accidental changes to the English language, that paralleling that was a series of much more deliberate changes to both words and how we use them and how they're spelled, and that just got us into more trouble. So what was going on there? How did that come about? Well, after the Norman invasion of 1066, anything official was in French.
当我们回来时，我们将与埃里卡谈论英语中我们只能怪我们自己的那些奇特之处。我们和埃里卡·奥克兰特一起回来了，埃里卡。在你的书中，你提到除了所有这些对英语的偶然改变之外，与此平行的还有一系列更有意识的改变，包括词汇、我们如何使用它们以及它们的拼写，而这只是给我们带来了更多的麻烦。那么那里发生了什么？这是怎么来的？嗯，在 1066 年诺曼征服之后，任何官方的东西都是法文的。
English was a thing you did in your daily life, but it wasn't considered a language of philosophy and art and education and high pursuits. But that did start to change, and when it did, there was a sense that, oh, we got to help fix this language up. Like, we want to have English literature. We want to have English translations and English education, but the language isn't good enough. It's not real language like Latin is. We need to make it less, you know, embarrassing. And that took some conscious attention. Well, describe that. Like, what are some of the things that they did? Like, what do they try to do? Well, part of it was a massive vocabulary influx. So,
英语是你日常生活中的事，但它不被认为是一门哲学、艺术、教育和崇高追求的语言。但这确实开始改变了，当它改变时，人们有一种感觉，哦，我们得帮着修理一下这门语言。就像，我们想要有英国文学。我们想要有英文翻译和英文教育，但这门语言还不够好。它不像拉丁语那样是一门真正的语言。我们需要让它不那么，你知道的，尴尬。这需要一些有意识的关注。嗯，描述一下这个。比如，他们做了一些什么事情？比如，他们尝试做什么？嗯，其中一部分是词汇的大量涌入。所以，
in domains like law and government and cuisine, the natural thing to do was grab the nearest French word. So, instead of writing a Germanic old English word like craft, you might write art. And so craft then becomes the lowly kind of work with the hands type situation while art is the higher pursuit. But they didn't use to have different meanings. They were real synonyms when they arrived and then they were sort of imposed on them and that bias persisted to this day in the case of art and craft. Yeah, yeah. If you would have translated it this way, but then it takes on a connotation of, well, who's using it? And what are they using it
在法律、政府和烹饪等领域，最自然的事情就是抓取最近的法语单词。因此，与其写一个日耳曼语系的古英语单词如 craft，你可能会写 art。于是 craft 便成了从事低下的用手工作的状况，而 art 则是更高阶的追求。但它们以前并没有不同的含义。当它们刚出现时，它们是真正的同义词，然后它们被赋予了某种含义，这种偏见一直延续到今天，就像 art 和 craft 的情况一样。是的，是的。如果你这样翻译它，它就会带有一种内涵，即，谁在用它？他们在用它
for? They also introduced a bunch of new terms that you call incorn terms. And these are kind of neologisms that are like trying too hard. Like can you describe some of these because some of these are really fascinating. Well, when people started trying to bring English up to speed by bringing in Latin, there's a lot of Latin words that got incorporated into English words like describe, explain, introduce. But then people started going a little too far, because with Latin you can put on a prefix and a suffix and you can make new words by putting pieces together and they started coming up with words like suppeditation, the act of supplying or adubitation, the act of supplying or a dupitation, the act of questioning oneself.
做什么？他们还引入了一堆你称之为“墨角词”(inkhorn terms) 的新词汇。这些有点像是用力过猛的新词。你能描述一下其中的一些吗？因为其中一些真的非常迷人。嗯，当人们开始试图通过引入拉丁语来让英语跟上时代时，有许多拉丁词被融入到英语词汇中，比如 describe、explain、introduce。但后来人们开始有点过头了，因为对于拉丁语，你可以加上前缀和后缀，通过把各个部分组合起来创造新词，他们开始想出诸如 suppeditation（供应的行为）或 adubitation（供应的行为，或质疑自己的行为），
There was so many of these that people started to get annoyed with them, and they were called Incorn terms, because scholars went around with these little horn belts that had ink in them for doing their scholarly writing. So it was a little bit like, these, these ink horn terms, they're filling up the language and they're too noticeable and they're trying too hard. But some of them continued in the language and now don't seem strange to us at all. Oh wow. So what are some of these Latinate words that were derided as ink horn terms for for being too complicated that nevertheless survived? Like what are some of these Latinate words that were derided as in-corn terms for being too complicated that nevertheless survive? Like what are some of those that we take for granted that were
像这样的词有那么多，以至于人们开始对它们感到厌烦，它们被称为“墨角词”，因为学者们随身带着这些装着墨水的小墨角带子来写学术著作。所以这有点像是，这些墨角词，它们塞满了这门语言，它们太显眼了，而且显得用力过猛。但其中一些词在语言中延续了下来，现在对我们来说一点也不奇怪了。哦，哇。那么，那些曾被嘲笑为因过于复杂而被称为墨角词，但最终却存活下来的拉丁语词有哪些呢？比如，那些我们认为理所当然、最初却被认为是荒谬的拉丁语词有哪些？
initially considered ridiculous? Yeah, well, you think of the word incorporate. There's a lot going on there. Like it's very complicated, but it doesn't seem complicated to us anymore. We have a natural relationship to it. It doesn't sound like a duetation or, quote, motoconquizing or things like that, that were these Frankenstein terms. Someone is commoto-comquizing. That was a word, meaning every which weighing basically. But that's not one that worked out or went on. No, you don't say. Other than vocabulary being introduced to formalize the language, where there are other things like plurals, anything like that, that sort of came when the learned classes were trying to sort of civilize English.
是的，嗯，想想 incorporate 这个词。里面有很多东西。就像它非常复杂，但对我们来说它不再复杂了。我们对它有一种自然的联系。它听起来不像 duetation 或诸如此类的动机复合词，那些都是科学怪人式的词。有人在进行“动机复合”(comoto-comquizing)。那是一个词，基本上意味着各个方向的称重。但那并不是一个成功或流传下来的词。不，你别说。除了引入词汇来使语言规范化之外，还有没有其他东西，比如复数形式之类的，是在知识分子阶层试图使英语“文明化”时出现的？
Yeah, well, much later, English started to be pretty proud of itself. Like, now we've got Shakespeare. Now we are a real language, but there's still this insecurity, and people start to write advice books that are sort of etiquette books. Like, no, no, this is the real proper way. And a lot of that came with pronouncements using Latin grammar still. So cactus, cacti, alumnus, alumni, and you see these in educated writing. You know that's the way to form the Latin plural. So it starts to spread and then you have a word like octopus. How are you going to put that into the plural?
是的，嗯，很久以后，英语开始为自己感到自豪。就像，现在我们有了莎士比亚。现在我们是一门真正的语言了，但仍然存在这种不安全感，人们开始编写建议书，有点像礼仪书。就像，不，不，这才是真正正确的道路。其中很多都伴随着使用拉丁语语法的宣告。所以 cactus（仙人掌）变成 cacti，alumnus（校友）变成 alumni，你可以在受过教育的写作中看到这些。你知道那是构成拉丁语复数的方式。所以它开始传播，然后你有了 octopus（章鱼）这个词。你将如何把它变成复数？
And octopus is as English. That's fine. It should be the English, but where you get that insecurity about whether we're right or wrong, when we come to one of these words that ends in us, what do we do? Oh, oh, oh, oh, and you think, okay, um, Octopi. Yeah, yeah, Octopi, that must be it. And then someone comes along and says, no, no, no, the proper plural of octopuses, octopides in the Greek. And then they've won up to you on your knowledge of classical languages. And that keeps us using these crusty old rules that don't really have a place in English
而 octopus 是很地道的英语。那没问题。它应该是英语式的，但当你对我们是对还是错感到不安全时，当我们遇到这些以 us 结尾的词之一时，我们该怎么办？哦，哦，哦，哦，你心想，好吧，嗯，Octopi（章鱼的错误复数形式）。是的，那一定是它。然后有人走出来说，不，不，不，octopuses 的正确复数形式是希腊语中的 octopides。然后他们在你对古典语言的知识上胜过了你。这让我们继续使用那些在英语中实际上没有立足之地的陈旧规则，
and we're consciously brought about, consciously put in there to elevate the language. And then what I was curious about is the PS and psychology or MN and Nimonic were those always spelled that way or were those added later to fancify things? Words like psychology and Nimonic were brought in as is much later. So those are people borrowing them directly from Greek translated into Latin and putting them into English. But some of them that we spell with these classical spellings in the beginning were spelled normally. So Flem and diarrhea. These were things we had and talked about in English. So Flem was F-L-E-M-E and Diario is D-I-A-R-I-A, but later during the sprucing up phase of the language, we made the connection back to their fancy roots, you know, elevating Flem in Diaria, putting the G in there and putting all these
它们是被刻意带来的、刻意放进去以提升这门语言的。然后我好奇的是，psychology（心理学）中的 PS 或者是 mnemonic（记忆的）中的 MN，它们一直都是那样拼写的，还是后来为了让事情看起来更高级而加上去的？像 psychology 和 mnemonic 这样的词是后来按原样引入的。所以那是人们直接从希腊语借用并翻译成拉丁语，然后放入英语中的。但在开始时，我们用这些古典拼写拼写的一些词其实是按常规拼写的。比如 phlegm（痰）和 diarrhea（腹泻）。这些是我们用英语拥有并谈论的事物。所以 phlegm 曾是 F-L-E-M-E，diario 曾是 D-I-A-R-I-A，但后来在语言的润色阶段，我们把它们与它们华丽的根源重新联系起来，你知道的，提升了 phlegm 和 diariia，在里面加上了 G，在里面加上了所有这些
ours in there and making it really confusing to spell. Is this sprucing up where the different English and American spellings of words like color and labor come from? Is that, or is that something completely different? Well, it seems like it would be, but it's more the British trying to separate themselves from the Americans. So for a long time, the O-R-U-R-O-U-R thing was back and forth with everybody. It wasn't standardized here, it wasn't standardized there, but then Webster's Dictionary came about and he wanted to simplify spelling and make it more American, more natural. So get rid of some of these unnecessary letters.
r，使得拼写变得非常混乱。不同英语和美式英语中 color 和 labor 这样的词的拼写不同，就是在这个润色阶段产生的吗？还是那是完全不同的东西？嗯，看起来好像是这样，但其实更像是英国人试图把自己和美国人区分开来。所以在很长一段时间里，O-R、U-R、O-U-R 的拼写在每个人之间变来变去。它在这里没有标准化，在那里也没有标准化，但后来韦氏词典 (Webster's Dictionary) 出现了，他想简化拼写，使其更具美国特色，更自然。所以要去掉一些这些不必要的字母。
And his first idea on this did not work. His original dictionary idea had, you know, believe spelled B-E-E-E-V and soup spelled S-O-O-P, and things we do not do. We did not take those changes. Nobody even tried, it was too hilarious.. You see the word spelled that way. But a few of those things did work. Like color is going to be OR. And in England, they were still back and forth on all these things. But once it was determined, oh, this is the American way, they said, and we're not doing it the American way.
他在这个方面的最初想法并没有奏效。他最初的词典构想是，你知道的，believe 拼成 B-E-E-E-V，soup 拼成 S-O-O-P，这些是我们不做的。我们没有接受这些改变。甚至没人尝试，这太荒谬了。你看到了这样拼写的单词。但其中一些改变确实成功了。比如 color 将会是 OR。而在英国，他们对所有这些事情仍然摇摆不定。但一旦确定了，哦，这就是美国人的方式，他们说，我们才不学美国人的方式呢。
Once you've spotted the difference, it's a choice to make yourself distinct. Some of my favorite examples from your book is words, you know, phrases that behave strangely not because of these larger, huge larger influences like the printing processor dictionaries, but just because they went on their own kind of whimsical journey, for example, the story of the phrase to egg someone on, it really does show this sort of like timing is kind of everything.
一旦你发现了这个区别，选择让自己变得与众不同就是一种抉择。我从你的书中看到的最喜欢的例子之一是那些单词，你知道的，那些表现奇怪的短语，不是因为印刷机或词典等更大、更宏观的影响，而是因为它们经历了一段属于它们自己的异想天开的旅程，例如，“to egg someone on”（怂恿某人）这个短语的故事，它确实展示了这种类似“时机就是一切”的现象。
And like, I guess you might say, can you describe what the phrase egg someone on is about? Well, that's egg someone on is a very old phrase, and we would have in English, an old English, it was more like edge. That would be the pronunciation, and that's what the word means to eggsamanan is to edge them on, sort of in the sense of you got the edge of a sword, making them go forward. Go on, go on, I'm edging you on. But we also were mixing in the very early days of English. We're talking, you know,
就像，我想你可以说，你能描述一下“egg someone on”这个短语是关于什么的吗？嗯，egg someone on 是一个非常古老的短语，我们在英语中，在古英语中，它更像是 edge。那将是发音，这就是 egg someone on 的意思，就是边缘化他们，有点像是你有剑刃，促使他们向前。继续，继续，我在边缘化你。但在英语的早期阶段，我们也在混合。我们在谈论，你知道的，
800s, 900s. We had Viking invasions happening in the north of England. And the Vikings had the similar language also from a similar Germanic route. So they had this edge word too, but they said egg. That was how they pronounced it. The Vikings had that hard g sound and a lot of the English words that have that hard g sound like give we got from them. And we adopted their way of saying egg on for edge on. And at the time we said egg differently. So egg was more like eye and then later we adopted the Norse or Viking way of saying that word too, which they had changed into egg. But again, with their hard G, the very strong hard G, they have a lot of influence that way. So our edge became egg and egg on and then our eye became egg and they just happened to sound exactly the same now even though they started as different words.
800 年代、900 年代。维京人入侵了英格兰北部。维京人也有类似的语言，也来自类似的日耳曼语源。所以他们也有 edge 这个词，但他们说 egg。那是他们的发音方式。维京人有那种硬 g 的发音，英语中许多带有那种硬 g 发音的词，比如 give，就是我们从他们那里得到的。我们采纳了他们说 egg on 的方式来代替 edge on。当时我们对 egg 的发音不同。所以 egg 更像是 eye，后来我们也采纳了诺尔斯语或维京语的发音方式，他们把它改成了 egg。但同样，凭借他们硬 G 的发音，非常强烈的硬 G，他们以这种方式产生了很大的影响。所以我们的 edge 变成了 egg 和 egg on，然后我们的 eye 变成了 egg，它们现在碰巧发音完全一样，尽管它们最初是不同的词。
You know, with all this insanity, it's easy enough to make the case that English is kind of the worst, you know, but you could also make the case that English is the best. Like, do all these irregularities and weird rabbit holes make English, like, kind of like the most fun in the end. Well, I think English has a unique position and it's definitely a world language. So many people use it that aren't native speakers and it has low startup costs. This is how it's been described to me by people who don't speak it as a native language, who learn it later. I think English, you can get up and going pretty fast.
你知道，面对所有这些疯狂，我们很容易得出这样的结论：英语可以说是最糟糕的，你知道的，但你也可以得出这样的结论：英语是最好的。那么，所有这些不规则性和奇特的兔子洞，最终是否使英语变得最有趣呢？嗯，我认为英语处于一个独特的地位，它绝对是一门世界语言。有那么多人使用它，而他们又不是母语者，而且它的启动成本很低。这是那些不把它作为母语、后来才学习它的人向我描述的。我认为英语，你可以相当快地上手。
Unlike other languages where you have to learn a lot of word endings or various conjugations, English, you got words and you put them together and you could start going with it. But then it just keeps opening new challenges for you, the deeper you get into it. And there are layers and layers and layers to discover as you go. So it's very impressive how people learn it so well and can get from layer to layer. And we should be more impressed about that. That's a wonderful
不像其他语言，你必须学习大量的词尾或各种变格，在英语中，你只需要单词并将它们放在一起，就可以开始使用了。但随后，随着你对它的深入了解，它会不断为你打开新的挑战。随着你的深入，有层层叠叠的东西等着你去发现。因此，人们能把这门语言学得这么好，并且能从一个层级跨越到另一个层级，这非常令人印象深刻。我们应该对此感到更加惊叹。这是一件美妙的
thing about the language. It makes it fun and we should respect it more. It should praise people more for learning English. Eric, thank you so much for talking with us. This was so great. Thank you. Well, it's great to be back. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background different wrinkles in English. There's so much more in the book, so go definitely check it out. It's available wherever books are sold. We'll also have a link on our website. It's 9i9pi.org. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Dara Hirsch, music by a director of sound, Swan Rihau.
事。这让语言变得有趣，我们应该更尊重它。我们应该更多地赞扬那些学习英语的人。埃里卡，非常感谢你与我们交谈。这太棒了。谢谢。嗯，很高兴能回来。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播客中介绍了很多英语中不同的奇特之处。书中还有更多内容，所以一定要去看看。它在各大书店都有售。我们的网站上也会提供链接，网址是 99pi.org。99% Invisible 本周由乔·罗森伯格 (Joe Rosenberg) 制作，达拉·希尔施 (Dara Hirsch) 混音和技术制作，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里豪 (Swan Real) 创作。
Delaney Hall is the executive producer Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Lashemadon, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of a Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now head to quartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California.
德兰妮·霍尔 (Delaney Hall) 是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德 (Kurt Kolstad) 是数字总监。团队其他成员包括维维安·莱 (Vivian Le)、拉舍·马登 (Lashé Madon)、克里斯·巴鲁贝 (Chris Baroube)、克里斯托弗·约翰逊 (Christopher Johnson)、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德 (Emmett Fitzgerald)、索菲亚·克拉茨克 (Sophia Klatsker) 以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分。现在前往加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，潘多拉大厦北面六个街区。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 9-9-PI-ORG. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu Tudu There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，以及节目 @99-PI-ORG。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你可以在 99pi.org 上找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜杜卡杜杜杜（Duddu）在特伦甘那邦的传统乡村游戏中发挥着关键作用。 这种游戏融合了策略和心理战，通过不断的抛掷和接球来决出胜负。